>> Chris Lambert: First a quick crown of introductions.
My
name is Chris Lambert. I'm a software engineer
working on
location base services, including Google Latitude.
>> Marcelo Camelo: Ah, I'm Marcelo, um, software
engineer on
the Maps API team in Sydney.
>> Dave Wang: Ah, my name is Dave Wang. I'm
with, ah,
Booyah. I'm the, ah, VP Marketing of Booyah.
>> Chris Lambert: Great. So today we're going
to talk
about, ah, a few different things. Um, if
you didn't get
the URL, it'll be on the -- the next slide.
But, ah, we're
going to start off -- I'm going to talk about
the state of
location APIs today, ah, and what Google makes
available and
how to use those. Then I'm going to switch
talking a little
bit about Google Latitude and we're going
to announce a new
location API, ah, related to Google Latitude,
ah, in this
session. And then, ah, talk briefly about
what this enables
before switching over to Marcelo who's going
to talk about
Places and how to, um, -- Well, I won't give
away
everything, but you'll find out. Ah, so today
there's a --
there's a number of APIs available for getting
location in
the browser. A quick show of hands, how many
of you are
familiar with the HTML5 Geolocation API? A
few of you.
Okay. So this, ah -- This is an API which
is supported in
Firefox 3.5, 3.6, and Google Chrome, um, and
the Android
browser in your Android phones. Ah, and basically
with a
few lines of Javascript you can get the user's
location and
use it within your applications. Ah, similarly,
there's a
Gears Geolocation API, which is compatible
with the HTML5
API but available in Safari and Internet -- Internet
Explorer. Ah, and there's also a Google Toolbar
implementation for Internet Explorer on Windows,
ah, that
also implements this HTML5 Geolocation API.
Ah, and this
API is -- is a great way of getting location
from the user
when you're -- ah, you have the user's attention,
they're
interacting with your application, and they
grant you
permission. It's a -- it's a really great
way to get
accurate location, um, more accurate than
IP address, which
is commonly used. Ah, and the way these -- these
work is
there's a -- a network location provider which
is built by
Google which takes a number of different signals,
um, looks
them up in -- in a big location database,
and then returns
the best estimate latitude and longitude for
the user. Ah,
in this same location, the writer is what
backs the Android
locate manager API, ah, that some of you may
have used. And
the way these APIs determine location is through
a mix of a
number of different location sources, ah,
which I'll talk
about briefly. So the -- the first which most
of you are
probably familiar with is IP geolocation.
Ah, this API
often gives you on the order of city-level
accuracy. Um, in
some countries it's -- it's only as accurate
as the country
the user is in, ah, but in the US it -- it
works pretty well
at the city level. Ah, this is really easy
to use. Um,
every HTTP request you receive as a developer
has an IP
address, ah, that -- that it comes from. So
if you just use
Google's AJAX API and send that IP address
off, you can get
a latitude and longitude for the city that
the user is in.
Ah, there's no power cost. It's really easy.
It's fast,
um, and it's not superaccurate, but sometimes
it's -- it's
good enough for what you need. Ah, there's
also cell tower
triangulation. And this works, um, well on
mobile devices.
Basically, any time you have a cell phone
that's connected
to the network there's, ah, one to a handful
of cell towers
within range, and each of these cell towers
has a unique
identifier. And if you send those -- if -- if
these
location APIs send those identifiers to Google,
Google can
look up, um, the positions of each of those
cell towers and
estimate the user's location from those. This
requires that
it be a mobile device connected to the network,
so cell
phone most -- most often, um. But -- but it
gives pretty
good accuracy, sometimes as accurate as -- as
the
neighborhood, ah, in -- in urban areas. And,
similarly,
there's a same type of location API, but,
um, builds off
Wi-Fi MAC addresses, which -- which gives
even better
accuracy down to the street level, so 50 to
100 meter
accuracy. And the way this works is -- is
the device,
whether it be a laptop or a cell phone, will
issue a
wireless, ah, network scan and look at all
the access points
within range of that device, take the unique
MAC addresses
of each, and then estimate the position based
on that. Um,
and this works even better. It's really popular
on laptops,
on cell phones. Um, and it's -- it's almost
as good as GPS,
but it has the advantage that it works indoors,
and it
doesn't have nearly the -- the same power
cost that GPS has.
So I talked a little bit about these, but,
um, I'll show you
exactly how this works. This is, ah, some
of our coverage,
ah, in -- in the San Francisco SoMa area.
So we're centered
on Moscone Center right now, which is where
we are. And you
see just within a few blocks of -- of where
we are, we have
thousands of cell towers, Wi-Fi beacons, MAC
addresses, just
-- They're everywhere. Um, and you could imagine
that right
now, if you -- if you did a Wi-Fi scan, you
might see 20
access points. So we just looked up where
those 20 access
points were and then basically return a point
near the
middle of those that we think best represents
your location.
So that's kind of what happens behind the
scenes when you
use one of these HTML5 Geolocation APIs. Ah,
zooming out to
San Francisco as a whole, you see just the
-- the coverage
area, um, in San Francisco is just so dense.
Pretty much
anywhere you are in the city, um, you'll have
great
coverage. Um, you'll see in Golden Gate Park
there there's
a little hot spot of red, which is the Academy
of Sciences.
So there's wireless access points there. Um,
in places where
there's not a lot of red, we actually have
really good cell
tower coverage. So you could get a location
fix even if
there are no Wi-Fi networks within range.
Ah, so we're
really excited about the location database,
ah, that we have
for cell towers and Wi-Fi networks. And, ah,
we're excited
to see it grow. And I want to point out that
there's
nothing special about San Francisco, that
the collection
methods that we have in San Francisco and
the partnerships
that we have are -- are worldwide. So the
coverage you see
here should be the same you see in any city
in the world.
And this -- this, as I mentioned before, this,
ah,
information is -- is easily accessible with
the HTML5
Geolocation API. Just a few lines of Javascript
you can get
the current location and show it on a map.
Um, the user has
to authorize permission. There's a little
bar that pops up
at the top of the -- the browser, but it's
-- it's really
easy to use, so easy that we're using it across
many of our
properties, so. Google Latitude uses it. Ah,
Google Maps
on the desktop uses My Location, same thing
on -- on cell
phones. Google Buzz uses location extensively,
search with
my location on Windows Mobile, on Android,
on iPhone, Google
Earth. Ah, we use it, basically, everywhere
it makes sense.
Um, but specifically I want to talk about
Google -- Google
Latitude. We launched Google Latitude a little
bit -- a
little bit over a year ago. Um, and it -- it
started off as
a way to share location with friends. So,
you assign it a
Google Latitude and, by the way, you all have
Android phones
now, so, um, just open up Google Maps and
put in join
latitude from the menu. We'll get you started
if you -- if
you haven't tried it yet. But, ah, you start
off with no
friends. Um, but you can basically add people
you would
trust to see, to share your location with.
Ah, and your
phone will actually report your location to
them
continuously, ah, so they can always see where
you are; you
can see where they are. Um, and you -- There's
privacy
controls to -- to control if you only want
to share the
city, or if you want to turn it off at night,
um, you can
just turn it off from within Latitude. So
it's a continuous
location sharing service. Um, and we've got
clients on
Android, Blackberry, Windows Mobile, Nokia,
iGoogle. Ah,
any mobile platform that we've been able to
-- to build
background importing into we've built a Latitude
client for.
Ah, it's been really successful. We have over
3 million
-- 3 million active users, um, and those users
are reporting
over 100 million daily location reports. So
that means
every day we see 100 million location reports
for these
users who are sharing their location with
their friends.
And one thing that -- that we've been asked
for, both by
users and developers, is it's great that Google
Latitude
lets you share location with your friends,
but what if you
wanted to share it with developers, developers
that you
trust who wanted to build applications on
top of this
location information? Um, it's not really
practical to have
multiple services running on your phone all
running in the
background, reporting locations, sending it
to a server,
eating battery, managing permissions. So our
solution to
this is actually to offer up a Google Latitude
API, which
we're excited that it launched today. So,
Latitude has
always put users in control of their privacy.
Privacy has
been kind of our number one story. Um, and
we've always
since -- since day one we've had per-friend
sharing and
granularity control . Um, because that's really
important
to users. So we're taking the same approach
with the API,
and users must explicitly authorize every
application that
they want to share location with. So if you
as a developer
want to access a user's location, there's
basically, ah, an
on-off flow. Um, a quick show of hands for
how many
developers have worked with Google's authenticated
APIs
before? [ pause ] Do you -- do you use APIs?
So, it's --
If you have, you'll be right at home with
this. It's a
similar model. Um, you send an on-off request.
If the user
approves, you'll then get an access token
that you can use
to access location. Um, when you request location
from the
user, we ask you to specify whether you want,
um, their --
the best available location or if you just
need the city
that they're in, um, and also whether you
just want their
current location or their location history.
In this way,
the user, ah, gets the ability to only grant
what they're
comfortable sharing. Ah, if the user doesn't
want to share
their history from the whole time but just
wants to let you
see what city they're in right now, that's
possible to do.
Um, it's easier to revoke access at any time.
And I want to
point out that there's no fire hose of data
here. This is
an individual developer-to-user relationship
that the user
is authorizing. Um, and it's also worth pointing
out that
this -- we're -- we're not sharing friends
locations; we're
just sharing the location of the user that
-- that you've
received authorization for. Ah, so I'll talk
a little bit
about the API. Um, it's an authenticated RESTful
API. Ah,
we have both JSON and -- and Atom varieties.
And all API
operations are -- are based on the concept
of the user
location. Ah, this is represented by a location
resource,
which you'll see on the next slide, but it's
-- it's a
really simple location object. Ah, we provide
two resource
collections in the API, which I mentioned,
current location
and location history. Current location is
just a
representation -- a time stamped representation
of where the
user is right now, so basically a latitude
and longitude
with a few other fields. Location history,
on the other
hand, is a collection of -- of every point
that -- that
we've seen the -- the user at. Um, so you
could imagine
running Latitude on your phones right now.
It'll report
anywhere from every minute to every hour,
depending on if
you're moving or if you're stationary. So,
for me, I have
location history for the last year or so.
Um, and I've got
I don't know how many location points that
are available on
my location history. So it's now possible
for me to offer
that up to a developer, um, and they can use
that location
information in -- in ways that -- that are
interesting. Um,
and, as I said before, developers can request
at, ah, best
available granularity or just the city. So
this is Location
Resource Object. Ah, the only three required
fields are
timestamp and milliseconds, the latitude and
longitude.
Everything else is optional. Um, accuracy
is pretty common,
but the other fields are mostly useful at
the location
that's derived from a GPS receiver. [ pause
] So, for
current location, there's a number of operations,
ah, that
we support. You can just fetch the current
location, which
is a really simple issue you could get. Um,
you can also
press location at the best available granularity
with the
granularity, ah, current parameter. You can
update the
user's current location with an HTTP POST,
and you can also
clear the user's current location if they
ask you to, or for
whatever reason, with the HTTP delete. Ah,
with location
history, ah, pretty similar model except we
also have a list
operation where you can query the user's location
history
based on the time range. So there's a max
time, a min time,
and a max results, ah, parameters that you
can use, and
those will basically return a list of location
resources for
the user. Ah, we let you fetch up to a thousand
in a
single, um, API call. Ah, but you could also
have the
option of just receiving an individual record,
ah, inserting
historical records. So you just insert at
the -- the
timestamp, and deleting historical record
as well. Ah, what
does the response look like? It's a simple
JSON payload
containing location resource, which you recognize.
In this
case, I requested city-level location. So
I just got the
latitude and longitude. Um, if there was an
accuracy that
would, ah, go along in there, um, which you'll
see in the
best available current location where I have
up an accuracy
and an altitude. So this location was imported
by a GPS
receiver. Ah, for history it's a similar model
except this
payload would be a lot larger. Um, this is
a query for my
last 10 locations before New Year's of last
year. So, you
could see where I was right before the clock
turned
midnight. Ah, as far as accessing the user's
location, ah,
I talked about the OAuth flow. This is just
the, ah,
visualization of what it looks like. Um, you
construct, ah,
an authorization URL that includes the granularity
you would
like access to, how much history you would
like. Do you
want access to all the user's history or just
their current
location, um, as well as their domain you're
authorizing.
And the user has the ability to see who's
accessing
my -- who wants my location? What domain is
it? Um, what
-- how much do they want? What granularity?
Do they want
history? And they can approve or deny it on
this screen.
Um, and as soon as that happens you're good
to go with your
API access. So, what does this enable? We're
really
excited about the possibilities. Obviously,
we -- we
haven't thought of everything. We can't build
everything.
Um, but we're really excited to see what you
guys can do.
And these are just some ideas. Um, one popular
example is
you go on a trip to Europe and you take a
thousand photos
and you come back. You can basically authorize
the service
to access your latitude location history and
your Picasso at
Baldems, and all of a sudden your thousands
of photos have
automatically geotagged to the exact point
where you were
when you took those photos. Um, you could
get alerts when
you're traveling and your coworkers are at
the same
conference as you. Ah, with the iPhone OS
4.0 now allowing
background location, we could see a number
of different, ah,
background location reporters that all push
location into
the Cloud. And then if a given application
needs it at some
individual time, even if that application
isn't running, if
it's a Web service, they can just query the
Latitude API for
that location. Um, and then there's a fun
example. If
you're driving home and your home automation
software
realizes you're, like, 20 miles away, so it
turns on the
heat. And your house is nice and warm by the
time you get
home. So, hope you guys have some -- some
ideas on what you
might want to build. But we're really excited
about this.
Ah, for more information, there's full developer
documentation at code.google.com/apis/latitude.
Um, their
support forms will be there, ah, release notes,
reference
guide. And then if you're just interested
in, ah, some of
the Latitude applications that are already
available
including location history, location alerts,
you can visit
the Latitude apps URL. Ah, if you have questions,
ah, you
can either come up to the mike or post them
on the Wave, and
it'll take questions at the end of this session.
Ah, but
first Marcelo is going to talk about taking
places, um, and
turning them -- taking locations, sorry, latitude
and
longitude, and turning them into a place with
more context.
Thank you. [ loud applause ]
>> Marcelo Camelo: Hi, again, my name is Marcelo.
I'm a
software engineer on the Maps API team in
Sydney. And I'm
here today to talk about Places and the Maps
API. Just, ah,
a quick summary of what I'm going to go through
in a couple
of minutes, ah, an overview of -- of Places,
what are
Places, why you should care about Places.
Um, also a little
bit about Google's vision of Place and our
offerings. And
then a bit of a hands-on exercise implementing
a simple Web
site that deals with Places. [ pause ] So
what is a Place?
Um, at Google we really like the full-length
definition. A
Place is any public location that people care
about. And
the main -- the main key word here is people.
Because no
matter what technology we use, no matter how
fancy
technology is, first you collect, ah, process
and serve the
data. If the final output is not relevant
to the user,
you're not really accomplishing your goals.
In -- in more
practical terms, Places can be of three world
categories.
They can be a point of interest. They can
be a business
establishment, or they can be a geographic
-- geographic
entity of -- of political boundaries. There's
a few
examples of what we think, um, about places.
So why as a
developer you should care about Places, the
main reasons
that Places can be much more meaningful to
you, to a user,
um, than a LatLng. They can also be a much
more compact
representation. Um, of course not in terms
of, um, start
requirements. I'm talking about the interaction,
the
conversation between users and your application,
right. Um,
a LatLng although is -- just do floats, it
usually requires
a map before the user can make sense of it.
Now, I'll give
you a quick example. I live in Sydney. I work
at Google,
but not at Googleplex in Mountain View. I
flew to LA. I
drove to San Francisco. Now I'm at the Moscone
Center. But
a lot of location information in what I just
said and you
didn't need a map to parse it and you could
parse it
instantly. So, in other words, ah, Places
much better
reflects the way people think and communicate
about
location. Um, another secondary reason is
that, ah, Places
can sometimes imply, um, subjective qualities
like personal
preferences. So another example, if I tell
you that
yesterday I was at an art gallery or a fancy
restaurant or a
museum, that tells you something about myself,
like my
personal preferences. So, again, it's the
people factor
that played here. [ pause ] Um, on top of
that, recently
there's been a lot of interest, a lot of buzz
around
location based services. I'm sure you all
heard of the
check-in based social games. There -- there's
a few of them
out there, and they're increasingly popular,
getting more
popular every time. Um, also a lot of buzz
around a
location based media and advertising, which
means --
customizing content and ads based on the user
location. So
that's, you know, it's a fantastic opportunity
for -- And I
just ran through this -- this number a few
days ago.
There's a study that shows that 53 percent
of people are
willing to disclose their location as long
as they get value
out of it. So it's up to us as developers
to create that
value. [ pause ] So what about Google? What
is Google
doing in this space? So we've been -- If you
think about
it, we've been dealing with Places since we
started working
on Maps, 2004, 2005. Um, we -- we process
a very
comprehensive -- that avails us places to
build both our map
tiles and our search indexes. Um, but until
recently we
didn't really look at this database from a
-- from the
perspective of a unified notion of Places.
Right? We -- we
had local listings. We had point of interest.
We had, um,
geographic entities, but we didn't look at
them as a
single -- a single concept. It was until recently.
Um,
late last year we thought of publishing what
you call the
Place Pages. Just a quick show of hands. How
many of you
guys are familiar with Place Pages? [ pause
] Okay. So,
what is a Place Page? So this is an example
of a Place
Page. All right, so a Place Page tries to
aggregate
everything that the Internet has to say about
a place. Um,
it includes pictures, videos, related Web
sites, maps, user
reviews, ratings. So, that is for it to be,
ah, a portal, a
Web portal for a geographic location. Um,
and our goal is
to have one Place Page for each -- for each
and every place
on earth. [ pause ] So what about developers?
Actually,
we haven't been doing a great job there. So
we heard a lot
from developers that they -- they miss, ah,
a native API to
do business search, for instance, inside the
Maps API. So
they're forced to use a separate API if they
want to do, um,
local listing search. That means dealing with
different
data types, different data formats, different
program of
conventions, which can all be very annoying.
Um, it means
not having a unified concept of place, which
means having
separate -- having to have separate lodging
for both dealing
with either geocode -- geocode address or
business listings.
Also it means different terms of service,
which can be a,
ah, a blocker for some developers, especially
enterprise
developers. [ pause ] So based on the importance
of Places
as a -- as a form of communicating location
to the user,
based on the increasing interest on location
based service
and also all the -- all the background that
Google has, all
the infrastructure and expertise on dealing
with Places, we
decided it was time to start handling, ah
-- bringing Places
to -- to a more -- making Places a first-class
season of the
Maps API. So we started with this, um, widget
that we call
Nearby Paces. And the goals of Nearby Places
is to help
developers connect users to places. Another
way to look at
it is to allow developers to harness Google's
Place
database. So we designed it based on two basic
use cases.
First, help users that are searching for a
place, then help
users looking to learn more once they find
a place, looking
to learn more about a specific place. And
also help users
to have conversations about a place. And I'm
just going to
go through a quick demo here, if everything
works correctly,
and show you how the widget works. So imagine
you're in
Sydney. Um, this is a picture I took -- actually
take by,
ah, p.m. 4. So you're in Sydney. You found
a spot with
this great view. You're looking at the -- the
Harbour
Bridge, the Opera House, and you drink your
beer. And you
-- you just realized, oh, I -- I found this
place on a -- on
a Web site. You had great reviews. That's
why I'm here.
Now that I'm here, I want to review this spot
myself. So
you bring up your cell phone [ pause ] and
[ pause ] there
it is. You go to A Review Website. So, the
phone detects
your location, tells you you're in the shores
of the Sydney
Harbour. Let me zoom out a little bit. So
this is the
Sydney Harbour. And you see this little button
at the
bottom of the page saying tap to select a
location.
[ pause ] So you tap it, and it lists all
the prominent
places around you. So you can see there are
business
listings there, restaurants, ah, probably
another, um, more
generic -- businesses as well, but also, um,
a geocode
result there. So, it's looking at places in
a more holistic
way, right? It doesn't have to be a business.
It can be an
address. It could be, ah, a landmark or a
beach -- a beach.
So you selected, um, at The Deck Sydney. [ pause
] And
now, let me try again. [ pause ] Oh, oh. I
probably
missed my -- my connection. Just a sec, please.
Yup. I
need to be connected to the VPN. [ pause ] Because
it's
not currently public. [ pause ] Come on, you
can do it.
[ pause ] Let me see first -- Okay. There
it is. So you
select the place. Now the Web site knows what
place you're
referring to, and it also gets back from the
widget, ah, the
metadata about that place. Um, you can see
a -- a bit of
the metadata there, so you get an icon representing
the
category of that place. You get the place
name. You get a
category. You get a user's rating with a -- represented
with the stars. It's a number from 0 to 5
or 1 to 5. You
get the full address, ah, both in stream form
and, um,
sorted form. You get a phone number. You get
the -- the
place position, which I used to fetch aesthetic
map. And
here I can say, hey, I like this place. All
right so now
the Web site displays a marker, and it's doing
its thing
there. So this place has received -- received
one posted
review so far. So if I want to rate another,
I'm back here.
I can get more places, if I did not find mine
on the list.
Ah, no. The place I'm looking for is not here.
So I can
enter the place here, or I can just say no
I don't want to
disclose my location. Right. [ pause ] So
if we go back
to the presentation. [ pause ] Okay, um, so
now I'm going
to go through the steps of implementing this
exact same, ah,
application. You guys are going to see it
is really, really
simple. It's almost plug and play really.
So the first
thing to do is to bootstrap the V3 API. How
many of you
guys use -- Or have you used the V3 API? What
about V2?
Cool. Um, so you have the Nearby Places widget
is -- or
will be part of the -- the V3 API. Um, you
don't have to
worry too much about code bloat, even if you're
not using
all the rest of the, ah, functionality of
the V3 API,
because the way the V3 API was designed the
user will only
actually download the code the application
requires to run.
And also it's really important to remember
to set sensor
equals true, if you're planning to use the
device's sensor
to geolocate the user. Next, you declare a
div, and you
create the widget instance passing that div's
argument to
the constructer. So I have the div at the
bottom of the
code snippet. I get element by ID, and I call
the
constructer of the Nearby Places widget. So
when you do
this, you get this standard button rendered
on that div. It
also includes the powered by Google. And the
-- the reason
we -- we have the powered by Google there
is because we want
to make sure -- clear to the user that the
position is being
sent to Google's server. [ pause ] So how
do you get the
user input? So when -- when the user clicks
on the button,
it displays the widget. When the user selects
a place, it's
going to change a property in the widget called
Place
Property. If you know V3 you can place even
listeners to
properties. In this case, it'll be, ah, the
place
underscore change will be triggered every
time the place
property changes. And, in this case, what
I'm doing is
whenever place property changes, I call get
place to get the
dollar structure, which represents the place.
And I test
for not empty, and then I call show dialogue
-- show place
dialogue with the -- the place metadata in
the place
structure. The reason I do test for place
not being empty
is because the way that we signal that the
user select not
to disclose a location is by passing, ah,
an empty object
there. [ pause ] So, one of the goals -- So
we're talking
about, ah, finding places around the user,
so that was use
number one. Ah, learning details about a place,
use case
number two. And use case number three was
having
conversations about a place. So what we wanted
to enable
with the API is allow people to have their
users selecting a
place, they get the place back, and then,
you know, they're
going to aggregate -- They're going to add
value to -- to
the place. If it's a review site, they're
going to
aggregate reviews to the place. If it's, um,
ah, say --
[ pause ] What was the example? It doesn't
cross my mind
now, but it's okay. Um, so those two properties
that you're
going to use to -- to establish this conversation.
The
first property is the id, the id that is to
allow users to
aggregate content about a place. Ah, the word
-- the
technical word that we use inside Google is
cluster, to
cluster information around the place. [ pause
] And this
schematic sort of tried to -- to show how
that's done. So,
the id you can think of it as a -- a foreign
key in your --
in your -- in your database. So you have a
table of
reviews. And you -- The id you're going to
use to link each
role into a specific place. But the trick
is you can use
the id to fetch the -- the place detail. For
this you have
the reference. So the reference is a way to
fetch a place
that you've -- that you've -- the user returned
in the past
and you want to fetch it in the future. So
you also store
the reference. So you have your data pointing
to your id,
which is linked to a reference. You use the
reference to
get the place result. So the way you get your
place result
from -- from a reference is calling the get
place by
reference, which is in the place service class.
So the
result is the same as when you do widget dot
get -- get
place, which is, ah, a place result object.
[ pause ] So
on top of the widget, we've also been working
on a Web
service that offers the same kind of functionality.
So the
difference that it's not a -- a Javascript
object. It's not
a Javascript implementation. It's, ah, HTTP
interface. Ah,
the main -- the main reason you would want
to use it is if
you're writing a -- a native app. So you're
not
allow -- you're not allowed to use Javascript
there. It
outputs JSON and XML. [ Pause ] So this is
an example of,
ah, finding places using the HTTP interface.
So you call
Maps API Place search, JSON, which means that
you -- you
want the result to be in -- in JSON format.
Ah, you pass
those arguments to location, radius, and also
sensor. And
the result will be a JSON object, which will
have the -- the
response status and the results, which will
be a list of
places. And in this results you'll -- you'll
have place
name, the types, the icon, and the reference.
So you can
use that reference. Then on the second use
case, which is
to get details about a place, so you call
Maps API place
details XML. You pass the reference as, ah
-- which is the
reference id that came in the previous result.
And you get
a place details response, which should have
all the data
that we use to display the -- the dialogue
previously.
We'll have the place name, vicinity, um, type
tags, phone
number, address, all the works. [ pause ] So
just before I
hand it over to -- to David, just recapping
the -- the main
message that I want you guys to -- to take
home from here.
Ah, first, Places. You should care about Places
because
it's a more friendly, user-friendly way to
communicate
location, right. Um, also there's a lot of
interest
in -- in based services. They're becoming
mainstream, so
users are much more open to providing their
location.
They'll be more open. And I believe that at
a point they
will start actually demanding, um, this type
of features
from -- from mobile applications. Google is
really, really
committed to providing high-quality location
based tools for
developers. This is just the start. Ah, we
have a lot of
ideas, and we plan to be working on them throughout
the
year. Um, use Near Place, ah, Nearby Places
to find, learn,
and have conversations about -- about places.
Um, we plan
to release it shortly, hopefully in the next
couple of
weeks. And more will be coming after that.
So watch this
space. So now I'll hand it over to David and
learn how he
has been using the -- the Place service.
>> Thank you, Marcelo. [ applause ]
>> Dave Wang: Hello, hello. Oh, cool. Um,
good afternoon,
everybody. My name is Dave. I'm the, ah -- the
VP
Marketing for Booyah. Um, so we're really,
really excited
about, ah, kind of talking how MyTown has
really kind of
layered on some of the gaming and entertainment
aspects over
the, ah, Google, ah, Places Web services today.
Um, and so
I don't know in terms of a show of hands who's
heard of,
like, MyTown or Booyah? Okay. Cool, cool.
[ laughs ]
Great. So I'll take a couple of minutes to
kind of talk
about this. So, I mean, as -- as, um -- as
Chris and
Marcelo talked about, a lot of these check-in
apps are
starting to become more and more popular.
Um, and, you
know, MyTown is certainly one, um, in that
class of
applications. And really what we do is really
bring much
more of a Mersive gaming approach to this,
ah -- to this
experience. And so what is MyTown? Ah, the
New York Times
kind of summarized it as a real-world Monopoly.
So instead
of playing a Monopoly game, you know on a
board game at
home, you can actually play Monopoly, um,
around in the real
locations. You can go and actually virtually
buy a Peet's
Coffee or a McDonald's or a Starbucks. And
other people
playing the game can kind of check in, and
you can collect
rent, upgrade your properties. It's really,
really fun.
Um, and so, you know, my previous company
we were looking at
location based services for about half a decade,
um, and
thinking, you know, utility, utility, utility.
But really,
you know, from Booyah's perspective, my current
company,
it's really through entertainment and gaming
is how we're
actually funneling a lot of location based
services through.
So, um, it's pretty fun and exciting. So the
concept and
the flow, which I'll go through in a demo
in a couple of
minutes is, you know, you start with the home
page, you
know, the sooner you can check out your town
and hit the
check-in button. And it uses, ah, ah, the
location of the
user. And that's where we kind of interface
with the, ah,
with the Place of services, ah, API. Um, and
then you can
actually interact with the different properties.
Um, and
we'll kind of talk about the context that
we brought to the,
ah, opportunity and the thought process of
why we were
really, really excited to partner with Google
as a -- as a
lead partner here. Um, just some superquick
stats and also
help with some context. We're growing superfast.
Um, we've
been out for about five months with MyTown.
Um, actually
over 2.1 million users now. We're, I think,
2.25 or
something. Um, the engagement is superhigh.
So people are
playing, like, over an hour a day on average.
So they're
really into the game. Um, and a lot of check-ins,
about 100
million a month. Um, and -- and, you know,
a hundred
percent of our user base is in the U.S.A.
And that's really
exciting, but, at the same time, it really
is -- the reason
why we wanted to find a partner who had that
international
scale. Because when you want to launch in
a hundred
countries over the next, ah, couple of quarters
here, ah,
there's a whole, whole web of contracts and
terms of service
from every different map provider. It's kind
of an insane,
ah, relatively intractable problem for a start-up
to solve.
And I think that, you know, Google, um, with
its kind of
best-in class performance enables -- You know,
you don't
have to cache stuff. You can do a lot of stuff
just real
time, and they've been able to solve a lot
of both the
commercial and the, ah, technical, ah -- technical
challenge
that we were facing. Um, so the context we
had is really,
you know, if Booyah really wants to become,
um, a leader in
real-world gaming, ah, we'd want these games
to be played
worldwide. And, you know, trying to, you know,
have a very
nice complement where we want to kind of -- You
know, we're
at the intersection of entertainment, social,
and location
graphs. Um, and we personally -- We made a
decision, a
strategic one, really not to, ah -- not to
kind of reinvent
the wheel, so to speak. We felt our value
at -- was the
application layer of entertainment on top
of the kind of
mapping and directory infrastructure. Um,
and we wanted to
find a partner who kind of had that similar
alignment of
roadmap both in terms of the core technology
but also on the
commercial side. Um, so that's kind of the
context of some
of the thinking. And I'm sure many of the
developers out
there probably mirror that. Um, in terms of
implementation,
there's a couple, ah -- a couple differences
here with the,
ah -- with the new services that we're using.
One is the,
ah, persistent location identification because
you need a
kind of a persistent ID. If you want to have
a game, and,
you know, Peet's Coffee has an ID, and you
want to layer
your gaming information on top of that, that
ID needs to
kind of be stable. If it's changing all the
time, it's hard
to keep that consistent, from both game play
and other areas
as well. And categorization is really important
as well
because it just makes the game a lot more
fun, and you can
get much more interesting signals coming in.
Um, the other
thing that was really cool was the, ah -- the
whole HTML pod
Place page. Because MyTown is an app on the
iPhone, so it's
an actual native application. And so the certain
cadence
and rhythm to submitting client applications
for approval
and having that marriage between, you know,
a client app
with a, ah -- a Web page that can, you know,
be dynamically,
ah, changing and updated is -- is a pretty
good, ah --
pretty good, ah, ah, combination there. So,
what I'm going
to do now is, ah, switch over to, ah -- to
my phone here and
just kind of walk through a, ah -- a brief
demo of, ah -- of
MyTown, ah, using -- using Google's, ah, Places,
ah, Web
services. And this will be live in a -- in
a couple of
weeks. So, this is our top priority to get
it out in the
market. Um, oops. Oh, okay. Those are my kids,
Damian and
Tyler. All right, they're twins. Hi, guys.
I'll just, ah,
log in real quick. Um, so this is MyTown.
And this is
MyTown. I am actually, ah, level 42. I'm pretty
rich in
MyTown. I got 312 million, ah, Booyah bucks
here. Um, I
can kind of pan around. Um, and you kind of
see Godzilla
kind of walking in the back of MyTown here.
But basically,
you know, the core focus here is I can hit
the check-in
button, and it actually, you know, hits the
Google servers.
And we get it to location. It sends back,
you know,
different locations, categories, and proximity.
Um, and
we're at the, ah, Moscone Center here. So,
I'm at the
Moscone Center. This is a process of what's
called checking
in, for those who, ah, don't -- don't play
the check-in
games. I can look at the proximity. Triple
green bars,
that's great, extra points. Um, and, you know,
maybe you'll
want to learn a little bit the Mos -- about
the Moscone
Center. So I'm looking at business details.
And this is,
again, we're locating the Place Page, ah,
that Marcelo was
talking about. And we can kind of, you know,
take a look at
the actual utility. I can, you know, call
-- call them up.
Um, oops. And I can check out, ah, the map
and other stuff.
Um, and it's all through the HTML5 integration
through the
in-app Web browser that we've done. Um, and
I can probably,
ah, kind of see what's going on. I prepopulated
things,
speaking at the Google I/O. Speaking at Google
I/O, Booyah,
sweet. Close up the Facebook. Ah, see here
and check in.
So I've, ah, checked in. I'm getting points.
I got a money
sack and some cash, sweet. And then I can
kind of, ah, look
in my different properties that I own in MyTown
here. Um, I
can actually upgrade, ah, the different properties.
I can
actually also edit the look. And I can apply
my little
plant here and move them around and kind of
decorate them.
And, um, basically a lot of, um -- a lot of
fun game play.
But really the foundation underlying all this
stuff and this
kind of user experience, um, is a rock solid,
um, location
mapping database. And that's what we've kind
of found with,
ah -- with Google in our partnership. So,
um, that's pretty
much all I got. Um, thanks. Any -- And I guess
we'll turn
it over for some questions. [ pause ] [ loud
applause ]
>> Chris Lambert: Where did it go? So, ah,
we'll take live
questions. It doesn't look like, ah, any are
submitted on
moderator, but -- [ pause ]
>> I've got a question for you.
>> Chris Lambert: Yup. Go ahead.
>> Um, this is harder. If you wouldn't mind,
if no one
else is here. Um, so first, ah, as far as
Place IDs go, ah,
I know this is something you haven't rolled
out just yet.
But the impression I'm getting is that this
is yet another
option for us to -- developer types -- to
add to our list of
Yahoo's IDs, Twitter's IDs, all the other
providers out
there who will give you an ID number associated
with the
unique LatLng point out there. I'm wondering
if there are
any plans in the works to coordinate between
these different
services down the line, and if Google thinks
it could
provide that. Um, I mean, in the -- back in
the old
geography world, these are called gazetteers.
I haven't yet
heard techy types talk about them much.
>> Marcelo Camelo: Um, yeah. I don't think
we have any
plans now to coordinate. [ pause ]
>> Um. Okay. So, um, ah, we're certainly -- we're
certainly aware that there are a lot of different
schemes
out there in terms of -- of place and geolocation.
Um, IDs,
generally speaking, are one of the most difficult
parts of
this project. Um, the natural expectation
of developers and
users is that they find a place. Um, we give
them an ID for
that place. Um, that if we -- if they find
a place the
following week and it's the same place from
the same ID, and
if they come back the following year and that
place still
exists, then they would get the same ID again,
and they can
use that ID to retrieve that place. Sounds
very simple. It
turns out to be incredibly difficult to do
right, because
the world is continuously changing under you.
And our
perception of what the world is and our understanding
of the
world around us continuously changes. So,
um, plus it -- it
-- there's a certain degree of, um, ah, sort
of subjectivity
as well. Right? Ah, I have a hotel. That hotel
has a gym.
It has a bar. It has a restaurant. Are those
separate
places? Are they all the same places? Um,
over -- Different organizations have different
opinions as
to what this is. And it's actually quite hard
to do this
correlation. So, the decision we made was
that initially,
for the purpose of just getting this out there,
um, we would
not worry too much about, ah, cross-provider
compatibility.
Um, but we'd just make sure that we had a
Place ID system in
place that would serve our developers well
and meet
the -- the -- their basic expectations of
what an ID scheme
should offer. Um, but, ah, there's been a
-- certainly a
lot of interest in, um, coming up with a -- a
more common
scheme or even, ah, if that's not practical,
coming up with
a clearinghouse kind of model where someone
figures out, you
know, the different places for different people,
um, and
allow users to sort of translate from one
scheme to the
next. And, ah, you know, whatever efforts
come -- come
together around that we'd certainly -- we'd
certainly be
interested in being part of that.
>> Chris Lambert: So, I'll switch to a moderator
question.
Um, Aaron asks, How does the registration
for applications
work if the Latitude API is going to be used
from a native
application on a mobile device? Ah, we currently
require
that there is, ah, some unique identifier,
which, ah, is a
domain name, which is registered with, ah,
Google's API
service in order to use the API. So if it
is an application
on a mobile device, um, you may have a domain
name or you
can just use app engine to get one, just something
to
uniquely identify your device that no other
application
developer would be able to use. Um, so, ah,
and then take
the other one too. Ah, Jeffery asked, Picking
up location
mobile devices makes sense, but what about
making it easier
to broadcast your location when logged into
a desktop
operating system? Ah, this API is actually
perfectly suited
to being used from the desktop. Ah, you could
probably have
a native application or a browser extension
that
continuously pulls your location, um, and
update it a bit
with the Latitude API. Ah, that's fully supported.
It
should work great today.
>> Two questions. One is, um, we saw that
Motorola
announced that they did a deal with Skyhook
to get,
apparently, better accuracy than the Google
solution. And I
wondered, ah, if you're using a Motorola device,
the feature
that has that, will -- will they still be
able to -- You
know, if you get a different location provider,
is there
some way to use that in the Places for accuracy?
The second
one is kind of related, which is, ah, what's
-- How well
does this is all work in a shopping mall,
which you have
different levels in the same location and
all that.
>> Chris Lambert: Sure. Um, so the -- the
first one, ah,
with -- with whatever phone, whether it's
an -- an Motorola
phone, an iPhone, or a GPS receiver itself,
but however the
location is determined, whatever API you use
to determine
the location, ah, you can send that into Latitude
API as it
is. Um, so if you -- if you use a -- a Nexus
One or if you
use a Motorola DROID, the location going into
the -- the
Latitude API would be whatever the location
provider
provided to you. Um, so it could be Skyhook;
it could be
Google; it could be anything. Um, and as far
as your second
question, I think that's more for --
>> Marcelo Camelo: Yeah, yeah, um. That's
-- that's a good
point. Um, we -- we rank places by relevance.
Right. And
there's a limit to how many places we return
with a -- on a
single query. And that's currently about 20
to 25. So if
you have more than that around you, or if
you're -- if the
accuracy of the geolocation is too large,
then there may be
a problem. But the idea is that we're going
to improve the
relevance -- As --as the system gets used,
we hope to be
able to improve the relevance by analyzing,
you know, what
places are actually popular. We even, you
know, depending
on the time of days. So it's at night, you're
more likely
to -- to be looking at a night club or a restaurant.
If
it's during the day, you're more likely to
be looking at a
dentist. So, it's -- it's a challenge. And
that's one of
the cases where -- one of the most difficult
cases. But
we're trying to -- We're going to try to tackle
that.
[ pause ]
>> Ah, hi -- at UC Berkeley. Ah, I was , ah
-- This has
been touched upon a bit, ah, in the couple
of questions that
have already been asked. But, ah, I -- I wanted
to sort of
get a little bit of more detail on how it
is, what -- what
mechanisms you guys are using in order to,
ah, cluster the
metadata and the, ah -- and the, ah, LatLng
coordinates to
constitute a place. So, and how do you sort
of keep track
or perhaps what are some of the plans for
keeping track of,
say, you know, ah, I just tagged -- Ah, five
years ago I
tagged this bar that happened to have been
there. But it's
no longer there and so it's no longer a place
and now I
gotta change all that. I wanted to just get
a little bit
more detail there.
>> Marcelo Camelo: That's actually a -- You
know, it still
works as a really, really big challenge. And
we -- we
haven't solved it yet. So --
>> How do you do it -- How do you do it now?
>> Marcelo Camelo: So, okay, so, um, that's
one of the
reasons why we have actually two tokens to
reference a
place, one is the ID and the other one is
the reference.
And the ID is sort of promising that we can
give you a
single token, and promises that token will
be both stable
and have good recall. We separate those into
two tokens,
and one of the IDs that we promise this is
going to be as
stable as we can. Ah, we're going to make
it as stable as
we can, and so the token we're going to make
as recallable
as we can. Um --
>> I was wondering if you could do like, ah,
I've -- I've
seen it done in other places, but perhaps
doing clustering
based on how the places are being tagged and
sort of
coupling that with the LatLng coordinates.
I don't know if
that's --
>> Marcelo Camelo: Well, currently all -- all,
ah,
clustering is done offline, right?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Marcelo Camelo: And it's based on data
that we gather
from -- from providers, both vendors and our
own internal
providers. And we -- As this API gets more
used, we
definitely plan to actually feed back that
-- the data from
its each usage, back into the clustering pipeline
--
pipeline, hopefully improve the -- the clustering.
>> Thanks.
>> For the, ah, Latitude API, you demonstrated
getting a
location based on the time. Um, is that a
-- you have to
have the specific time stamp of the location
or is that, ah,
a location around here? And if -- if it's,
ah, more
generalized, how do you do the integration
between locations
that aren't right now?
>> Chris Lambert: Right. So, ah, current location,
ah, you
don't have to specify the time stamp. We'll
just take the
user's most recent location. Um, so there
-- there you're
good to go. You just access the current location
call. Ah,
for historical location, you access it by
time range. So
you can specify today; you can specify this
hour; you can
specify this exact second, um. But we don't
actually do
interpolation, ah, of location time stamps.
>> So if I -- So if I want the user's location,
I have to
ask you for a range around that --
>> Chris Lambert: And -- and you can --
>> A bigger range -- a bigger range?
>> Chris Lambert: Yes. So, like, if you wanted
to know
where I was at lunch today you could request
today and then
look at kind of what's the most accurate location
reports
within some time frame you would just define
as lunch, so.
>> Yeah. Um, was the Booyah app that we saw,
was that the
HTML5 Geolocation API?
>> Dave Wang: Yeah.
>> Okay, so, um -- I didn't --
>> Dave Wang: I think so. I'm -- I'm a marketing
dude, so
I think so.
>> Okay. My question was I noticed whenever
you, ah, fired
up the app that it didn't -- at least unless
I missed it --
it didn't send out the this app's trying to
use your
location.
>> Chris Lambert: So, it -- um --
>> Dave Wang: Oh.
>> Chris Lambert: That iPhone app was actually
probably
correlated.
>> Dave Wang: Yeah. I can -- I can actually
answer that
because, ah, I can fiddle with it. And so
if I actually do
something specific, like get directions or
something like
that, then it actually will pop up a window
to say, Are you
allowed to use the location? Um, so I -- I
don't think I
showed it in the demo, but it does have it.
>> Okay. I guess my question was I'm pretty
sure, ah, at
least defining the API, they say that they
want you to pop
that up any time. My question was kind of
is there, ah,
sort of a more aesthetic way to do it? Or
is there a way to
kind of set it to this person is clearly wanting
to interact
with this app? We don't need to bug them every
time or
trying to query their position. Or is that
just part of the
default API?
>> Dave Wang: Um, right now we are doing,
I think, just the
default. Um, so, you know, certainly it's
something we'll
explore, but right now it's just really we
hand it -- When
you're in that browser, we just hand it over
to Google.
>> All right. Okay, cool. Thanks.
>> You mentioned that, ah, when you provide
LatLng and you
get back a list of what the location might
be that it's a
relevant sort of list of, say, 20 results.
Is there any
notion of that being personal relevance based
on the
identity of the user sending it back into
historical or
their friend's activity?
>> Dave Wang: Right, right. Um, so the current,
um, ah,
implementation when you hit the check-in button
we do
actually just directly look at Google's, um,
you know,
basically, essentially a place rank or page
rank of places.
Um, in terms like Learing on additional intelligence
within
a specific context of our game, um, those
are things that
are kind of in discussion right now. But right
now
we're -- we're quite pleased with what we're
seeing by
Google by default.
>> So just global. Okay.
>> Dave Wang: Yeah. [ pause ]
>> Hi. If a business, um, decided to move
locations, how
would you handle that?
>> Marcelo Camelo: Yeah. That's -- that's
one of the
challenges of the idea of having stable IDs.
Ah, so what if
the business moves two stores down? Like is
it the same
place? What if it moves 200 meters down, is
place? So that's -- that's the subjective
aspect that were
mentioned. We -- we honestly don't have a,
ah, ah, answer
to that yet. Um, our -- our clustering are
written. They
have some heuristics. So I know that if -- if
a place moves
just less than 200 meters, it's considered
to be the same
place, because it could be just a -- a jitter
in the -- in
that. If it moves more than that, we consider
that it's
actually moved, and it's, ah -- it's a new
place. But
that's -- You know, there are other challenges
as well.
What if the places change name, and they change
names all
the time, not because the business change
names but because
the -- the data provider improves the data
or makes the data
worse. So something that's called Jackson
and Son's, um,
Meat Shop can become Jackson's Family Meat
Shop. So is that
the same place? Um, so we have heuristics
to that, and it's
really hard for me to tell where we draw the
line. And the
-- the -- the line changes every time, so.
It's a
challenge.
>> Chris Lambert: Ah, in front.
>> Thanks. Maybe this is sort of more a question
about
underlying location APIs, but thinking ahead
in terms of
the -- the growing set of applications you
-- you might see
here. Um, let's say the relationship between
location and
requirements like E911 where things -- Again,
thinking ahead
to applications where -- where the line may
get a little
fuzzy with respect to, ah, entertainment versus
convenience
versus maybe something related to, you know,
safety, ah, in
the future. For instance, is there a -- is
there a level of
granularity that says this is E911 compliant
-- compliant
location; go ahead use it?
>> Chris Lambert: Um, so there's nothing in
the APIs to
address that now. But I -- I suspect that
whether at the
browser level or the -- the OS level or whatever
the device
that actually has -- these -- API would -- Yeah.
So I
don't know how that would work. I haven't
thought about
that. But that's -- that's an interesting
question.
>> Okay.
>> So, for the Latitude APIs, ah, we're going
to need a time
stamp, obviously, to log, ah -- to log when
the current
location is. Um, how do we manage time zones?
Um, do you
guys handle the time zones by assuming that
the time that we
record the entry, if it's a live entry, has
got to be within
the time zone of the geocoordinates and then
compute it and
so that we can have, ah, an absolute timestamp,
or --
>> Chris Lambert: Ah, yes. So if you -- if
you update
current location, it'll actually take the
current time you
specify. If you update the historical location,
ah, you
specify the -- the milliseconds, ah, in GP
time.
>> Yeah, but since there's no, um -- there's
no time zone
variable in the, ah -- in the documentation.
Say I travel
from LA to, ah -- Say I travel from Europe
to Los Angeles.
Ah, so I take off at 4 p.m. and I'm going
to land at 5 p.m.
But nine or ten hours has spent since. Ah,
are you going to
be able to fill in that gap, or is it going
to be marked as,
you know, one hour ahead only?
>> Chris Lambert: Um, so yeah. For the -- the
case you're
on the plane there it would actually be two
location
history, ah, entries, one before you left
and one when you
landed. Um, and we don't do any interpolation
on our end.
So if you wanted to figure out the flight
path or something
there's a -- then you -- you can do that.
You could just
request the time range and then fill in the
-- fill in the
gaps.
>> Got it. Thank you.
>> Chris Lambert: Okay.
>> Ah, can you give us, ah, just a little
insight as to what
you expect in the Nearby Places in terms of
service and
licensing?
>> Marcelo Camelo: I'll defer that to Torr.
>> Hmm. [ pause ] [ sniff ] [ pause ]
>> Okay. The question du jour. Um. [ laughs
] So, um,
the Nearby Places widget will probably just
automatically go
in V3. And, um, as such you would be subject
to the same
terms, um, the rate of Maps API. The one -- I
-- I should
caveat by saying the terms of service will
be updated, um,
to extend to local business listing data,
because this is
the first time we've had local business listing
search
integrated into the Maps API rather than in
a separate, um,
business listing search service that Google
provide -- provides. Um, so the existing Maps
API terms has
some restrictions around long-term service
of data. Um, and
one of the reasons we have this IE scheme,
um, is, um, to
allow a -- ah, developers to build the plan
of applications
we expect they're going to want to build,
um, without
falling foul of some of those limitations.
Now, the,
um -- I should also point out that, um, this
is somewhat of
a -- a technology preview. Um, this is not
going to be
available, like, today. Um, we're going to
start -- We're
going to put some docs up so you could also
see -- um, see
what's coming. But, ah, we should have, um,
all this
launched, um, ah, probably July; I would say.
That might --
That's how it's looking. Um, the Places Web
service is
quite a different animal. Um, we have some
-- Local
business listing data generally is, ah, is
unusual, um,
relatively speaking compared to some of the
other types of
map data that we deal with, in terms of the
way it's
licensed, the cost to us, as are other complicated
things,
which means that, um, we have to take somewhat
stricter
precautions against sort of abuse and misuse
of them.
Perhaps we've had to deal with some of the
other services in
the past. So the Places Web service will still
be part of
the Maps API. It will still be part of our
suite of Web
services that we have, directions, geocoding,
elevation, and
so forth. Um, but it will have some stricter
authentication
requirements around it, and some stricter
-- some more
precise, um, sort of acceptable use guidelines
that you'll
need to meet. And as a consequence of that,
um, we will
require that developers sort of, ah, um, provide
us with
some credentials, um, to use the service,
um, and, ah, and,
um, sign their request so that we can authenticate
them.
Um, now, this is not a sign of things to come.
I know, ah,
some people might be worried this is sort
of the tip of the
iceberg thing. I mean, we've just taken keys
out of V3, and
we're coming back with all these new requirements,
you know.
It is very -- very specific to this service.
Um, what we do
plan to do -- and this should be out, um,
within the -- the
next hour -- is start collecting interest
in this service,
um, today. So, if this is something that you're
interested
in, um, there will be, ah, documentation going
out today
that shows you how it works. You can sort
of figure out
whether this will -- will suit you. Um, I
should stress
also that, you know, right now it's really
designed to do
these kind of check-in star applications.
It's basically
around-me type searches. Um, we don't have
sort of free
text searches in there yet. They're kind of
more complex
local business listing searches; that will
all come in time.
Um, but yes we'll start, ah, ah -- you could
start,
um -- You can sort of register your interest
today, ah, as
of today, and then we'll, you know, we'll
get back to you
once, ah -- once we're good to go.
>> Chris Lambert: So -- so we are -- we are
out of time,
but, ah, we'll be available outside after
for more
questions. There's a few more of you.
>> Dave Wang: Thank you. Thank you, everybody.